yeah we're all looking for that's all
we're gonna do man so it's healthier
that's a healthy snack then again no
pressure if you don't want to do it you
don't have to do it
now that looks like bobby the lower one
what is that that's an ewok
it's an ewok
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you
not as dude this time no those kids are
cool man where are those new balances
no these are uh can we talk about
catchers and our sketchers can we talk
about them yeah
yeah these are um yeah i'll just wait
yeah i'll explain
those are nice man aren't they did you
make those or you bought them
that's a legit question because i've
never seen them before yeah sneakerhead
yeah well i i i feel like you're our
test ar
you're an artistic guy yeah i feel like
you could put that together and just say
el nino on the side
no it's uh these are called uh
li ning you ever heard of this i haven't
brenda i'm not japanese no this is this
is the um
chinese version of nike i think oh
really
uh i i'm not i'm not do they pay the
workers they're the same as nike can i
see that
you sure you didn't make it
those are dope i'm not accusing you i'm
just saying you know what they're
interesting right i'm not a big
uh i'm not a big sneaker guy i wear the
same [ __ ] every day
i am and those are sick i'll definitely
check them out do you think they have
size 13 for bigger guys yeah the fairfax
you know where the oh
fairfax you know where supreme is yeah
yeah those are said these are
we used to wear theirs or what go ahead
stevie so these are really interesting
because they specialize i think in
basketball shoes
oh but i saw these and i'm like well
i've never
you know there's they're colorful and
they have them um they kind of
you know new balance yeah they kind of
remind me between like new balance and
saccones
but you know what's interesting is the
the um there was uh it kind of seemed
like just balance okay you're gonna be
able to balance
the wuhan special yeah yeah for sure but
you see the
meat pocket the foam yeah that's it so
there's foam here and then they had a
tag i ripped off that the tag on the
outside
oh like an off-white shoe yeah like a
mattress it's a real [ __ ] boy move to
leave the tag on
no no no i don't do that stuff that's
like doing it on your head yeah i'm not
yeah i'm a [ __ ] boy but there's a limit
yeah
oh yeah you're a real you're a whole
orgy of [ __ ] boy thanks for
complimenting this oh yeah you better
thank you
i saw those right when i came in thanks
for the juice daddy good to see you man
cheers good to see you man
glad you're feeling well come back to
l.a you get started getting juicy
hey how to do it man um
what else stevie where you been so i
know now what are you hitting right now
are you hitting enough
you want to try one of mine you want to
step up to the big league can you throw
me one of these shout out to rogue thank
you
oh wow oh you like the mango huh oh dude
is he going to pass out no what
milligrams are the ones you usually take
so i i do this this is what i'm trying
to quit
uh that's like choo choo yeah this is uh
i've been doing this for you i want to
see you go full jaw i don't even spit
doing this
yeah i want to see you like pete roll it
off yeah i just oh you swallowed
okay yeah i just fall asleep with you
here's the here's the thing
i fall asleep with mine too you can wake
up high
so you're looking to drive trucks i
guess so yeah
now you know i know you're on the market
this is four all right these are sixes
you'll be fine
and i do three of them i want to get a
little buzz yeah get you a buzz dog
now uh with the real chew like you're
chewing like a like
feels like a truck driver this the
ladies don't that's frowned upon in the
with the ladies
oh but i might you know the lee brothers
we don't even go to the dentist we'll
just let it fall out
you like the yellow yeah we just they
let it fall out and make chest pieces
out of it haven't you ever been
abroad i have to i really haven't i got
stuff to learn
yeah the ladies don't like this no plus
my breath already really smells
like poo so yeah [ __ ] breath i brush a
lot too
i think it's like genetic huh have you
smelled bob's breath
oh yeah poo his breath like a cat that
kind of a not feeling well cat yeah like
a dead kid have you seen his feet
i have not seen his feet dude feet it's
like frankenstein
little feet though right but like
gangrene now did you get any [ __ ] for
being on the show last time from the
boys back there with bad friends
oh my god what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean you know what i
mean no we patched it up
you guys are good no no we're good okay
that was just a one-off and
we did it for promotion i wish you would
have stuck with it but what can you do
yeah well what could we do
i mean i don't want to you know we're
just trying to water under the bridge
we're just trying to like yeah
oh so y'all didn't really have a fight
with santino
not really it was just he was just mad
because you know bad friends good
friends but it was a one-off because you
know that that was the week it was
april fool's oh so we did it as a
promotion as a joke you know what i mean
it worked i feel like you got a lot of
promotion out of it yeah have you guys
seen scissor bros
i have i don't believe you yeah please
don't
when i say i have means i see the post
on instagram but you didn't see the
bengay on the nuts and dick
no we don't throw a look so we put
bengay on our
nuts are you nuts yes trying to go viral
well i was
i'm trying to think that way yeah are
you though
yeah who doesn't that's the challenge it
won't solve anything dude i put in the
sport of my muscles last week because i
was insane
from working out have you put it in your
home butt hole though
so we did nut sack penis and butthole we
put on the tip
the whole thing why are you doing that
man growing up
dangerous no but it's a challenge
because to who could endure the most
pain
you know it's also a challenge not to do
that kind of stuff and just be a good
adult yeah just be fun
and stay out of your own blood it's fun
to write was it good did
the fans like it yeah were you guys
freaking the [ __ ] out well we should
have used tiger balm
oh yeah why didn't you i know using
these imported
they changed the formula of ben gay
because bob made me p he's like
as a kid he was like you wanna you you
know what feels like a [ __ ]
and i go no he goes ben gay and i
remember putting ben gay on
it does not feel like you're blind i ran
into the shower
yeah oh it burned yeah it feels like a
[ __ ] with [ __ ]
fire i don't want to be picturing two
asian naked children either
just because i don't want to picture any
naked children and in this vision they
happen to be asian because you said they
were
yeah and it's bobby convincing you to
put ben gay oh yeah
and you didn't do stuff like this as
kids nope
never did that never went down i don't
think so did you do that [ __ ] i never
dude look at that tattoo on your arm
what
is that bobby no which was show that
tattoo to the camera real quick
no the other one right by your sleeve
right here
yeah no the other one right up by your
sleeve if you don't mind peanut butter
falcon bobby lee show that to the camera
does that not look strikingly like
like the piece of art that you drew last
time oh i customized this tattoo
well yeah they look like why did you
just
keep it man what do you mean that's hall
of fame material dawg
that's a what is of art
bobby bobby it's on your arm this is
like memento
this is called love though oh that's
your girl
no this is my brother oh this looks like
that a little bit that's all i was
saying
i would say almost identical my brother
would be
so mad that who was your brother he'd
passed away
no this is bob oh jesus but why would
you get a tattoo he's alive
i know but he has my name on his arm oh
who's a tattoo artist
oh a guy from san diego uh island tattoo
oh wow yeah
oh that sounds like a nice place i know
this is disrespect this love
oh i first of all it looks that looks
this is love
it does not look like him at all it
looks like the fourth stooge almost if
you had the three stooges and you know
it doesn't look like my brother it does
right not a lot bubba
it it it it looks it looks like the best
hour's working on this design
really that looks power dude that looks
like bobby if he was a zombie
that is a scary thing it looks like the
fourth one of those guys almost if you
put him in there a little bit
hey no no this is my brother
yeah but you know what you could do to
get your girl back show her that
i've moved i'm trying to move on i'm on
dating apps now
are you that's what i'm talking about
yes good for you getting out there yeah
have you had any experience like i have
trouble whenever
date naps make me feel sad a lot of
times does that happen to you or not
i've just been getting scammed i erased
it already oh you did
yeah i got two scams did you send
somebody money how'd you know oh how did
you know they asked for that
okay that's the scam that's the oh no if
i just get three hundred dollars for an
uber and then they never show no i i
don't know uber from
maine yeah yeah it was a ukrainian model
oh and and uh she was talking to me and
i said hey cause she had a dj picture in
there and i go hey what do you spin and
she goes
blah blah blah edm can you send me money
let go what do you mean
demon warm up my grandfather's moving
from
ukraine and i need money legit point
second one
no who's moving what hot girl is moving
their grandfather in to live with them
but also
dow did you send money no i i
blocked okay but the second one was more
sketchy
it was another a russian model
and i i moved it to instagram that was a
mistake
so i i was on instagram and then this
other
profile was simultaneously
uh dm'ing me and it was a missing
person's report
wow from germany oh wow so it was this
like
passport of the girl i'm the tinder girl
from a different account so what are you
getting into man
yeah what dating site is yeah how can
this dark web
site tinder i thought you didn't even
know how to dm this is getting hella
cambodian
it's just you're in a ponzi scheme have
you had have you had anyone
any real connections have anything
nothing
i've gotten matches but zero i don't
know the opening what do you say is the
opener
we matched yeah seven picks at tattoo
what do you think
yeah what do you think of my brother no
it's 90
or 7 80 75 85 95 bots
wow sounds like a new dating site which
is the
right one to do though aren't there some
good um kind of far eastern sites or is
there anything that's specific to that
like asians only yeah it's called um
there's farmers only
there's black there's short black black
black they're short kings which our boy
is on
hinges for i think called carpenters or
something is it but now it's bumble
but what about raya oh bumble could be
phrased oh ryan's for the big players
now doggie
what's that that's where like you know
ben affleck
i'm beta bucks so you guys are that you
know but i'm just saying
is there a specific i mean is there a
certain type of woman you prefer that's
why i'm trying to lead you in a
direction that could be helpful yeah
because we might be able to help you out
all right look look in a tiny apartment
man a couple of men got together and
they came here
and you know what happens then they
created a
company called movement that's right
movement watches man
i'm a watch dude man and what do you
want you want a sports dive watch what
do you want you want to go down 100
meters looking for gold whatever you
want to do we got you covered man
you want that business attire movement
watches have the look and quality of a
400 500
watch forget all that noise man we're
talking about great watches
at a great price if you want to elevate
your looking style that doesn't break
the bank
then join movement get 15 off right now
with free shipping and free returns
by going to mvmt.com
somebody's watching me go get your watch
get your time
up nothing's more sad than you meet your
girlfriend's grandmother and she asks
you what time it is and you don't know
you standing there
like a donkey bro like a timeless donkey
don't be a timeless donkey
if you want to elevate your look with
style that doesn't break the bank
join the mvmt and get 15 off today with
free shipping free returns
go to mvmt.com kats
again that's mvmt.com cats
dude my girl had her birthday we got our
anniversary there's mother's down
what am i gonna do and then my boys that
blue now said holla
i said what's up boys they said listen
man
we got something baby with your
customize and engagement ring or design
a diamond study
fans at bluenow.com
man bluenow.com is the original online
jeweler since 19.
millions of couples create their perfect
engagement ring all right
we got you covered make the moment
sparkle with jewelry from bluenow.com
every order is insured ship free arrives
i'll handle this you freak go to
bluenile.com
today go to bluenow.com and keep
distinct listeners
get 50 off of 500. that's right podcast
exclusive offer use code kats
that's code kat
there's a girl right here that has a
question for you related to the raya
controversy what are you guys doing here
this is joe and i'm currently living in
ireland i love the show guys
but i have a question so ben affleck and
matthew perry have had some super weird
interactions on dating apps that were
posted on tick tock
so i just want to know are you on the
side of the actors or the side of the
girls
love the show again and shout out to all
my black irish people
love you guys bye love you girl here's
here's the thing before you comment on
it now
that girl on that ride got a little bit
of trouble because here's the thing
she's a story she's a loser so so riots
for like
successful like famous people to find
love like dating apps and there's a
bunch of instagram thoughts on there
so like ben affleck and the guy from
friends is on there
the guy from friends you know he matched
with this girl
and the girl outed and was like look at
this creep going for a young girl i
guess she was 19.
but he was never like even the girl in
her friend post was like he was never
creepy never asked anything creepy we
just matched
and then i started hitting him up and he
called me here's where it gets weird so
she
out him so he looks like a creep in her
profile it says
i only like older men that was her one
condition i only go for older men and
then she's like this older guy is trying
to hit on me
that's bait that they're baiting well
it's just clout chasing their shoes
this is the ben affleck one actually
getting up in the morning these girls
are just doing this again so
it's just some sort of clout it's sad
it's sad it's weird
the world's coming to this
why did you unmatch me it's me
that's [ __ ] batman dude that really
is no that's not batman that's batman
behind that's
that's ben affleck at home so what's the
story what's happening who's that girl
and then i know
she just adam was like look at this
creep trying to hit him you're on raya
but here's the thing also you matched
with them you have a choice you're an
adult if this girl is 11 if this girl is
16 or 17 in a state where you can't
shake
you can't be on the app though right
right and you shouldn't be
but if you're an adult and you match
with somebody and then you're talking to
him then you out of this
it's just it's really sick what's this
girl's name uh naveen
well ryan kicked him off ryan kick them
off kick the girls off yeah good they
should
they should do a background check man on
your your real age
right i think they do i don't know the
app no
i have some friends on the app i think
they take their you're like i don't know
are you on it
on raya you're famous enough beyond raya
no i did i got him right when it first
what do you want me i'm trying to learn
from you guys let me
i want to learn i'm not that's why i'm
asking you if they're don't ask me i'm
making the mist
wrong decisions but are you really ready
to get back out there man i worry about
it you know
you're right i'm not even ready huh i
made a pro con list the other day i was
thinking if you were ready to get back
out there
no no no more cons and pros it had about
six cons on it
no i like being alone you like being
alone yeah playing video games and [ __ ]
no i just
it's good to be alive i'm not even right
i don't want to relax now be comfortable
in your own skin before you start
getting a relationship are you just
looking for intimacy
ooh good question i get horny man that's
fine if you are there's nothing wrong
with it
what i like to do is i send in a little
parachute guy and then it's like hey i
know somebody slid in your dms but has
anybody ever oh the emoji game
yeah baby creative so tell me and i
don't hear back what's that line again
neither do i what emoji is that one it's
like a vietnam
you have to have the vietnam emoji set
but i send the guy without the gun i
send the guy just the
medic the more friendly one yeah yeah
how do you do that do you do the
basketball hey
i rolled my ball here oh no that is for
pedophiles
oh i don't know i just saw that on
google though especially if it's a
kickball that's definitely
not a basketball a basketball bathroom
you go balls in your court
balls my ball rolled in here
i don't like that that's creepy that
means i want to eat wear your skin
i would roll the basketball and go balls
in your court
and that's how you open it and then so
if you hadn't so
tell me so tell me has any have you
gotten into any have there been any
dates that have gone on tell me about
the love man
i just want to know that you have love
in your life and people that care about
you man
because i know you and bob are kind of
y'all's relationship is kind of
unraveled
and i know that he you know they lose
interest though i think i think brothers
lose interest all the time look my
brother didn't talk to me for like two
years once
no the gals will lose interest because
are you talking about the girls yeah you
[ __ ] it up do you think you [ __ ] it up
because you say
i i say too much is it that or you're
like hey i'll get back to you after
seven hours of these video games are you
playing i don't play that
much really oh a couple two two three
but i think what would help us if we
knew your type
that would help us figure this out how
about if i just
be alone the thing is the masturbation
doesn't help you know what i mean
and when you masturbate are you using
which are you you don't even want to do
you want to open you want to open up
that door
yeah we do we're knocking let us in dad
i mean
i have uh all the pocket [ __ ]
i got all the ones oh my god he said
pocket [ __ ] are you really
no those are made in china aren't they
yeah i've done it yeah i've done it i
would not i would
yeah you got to squeeze oil in it and
everything
oh man
oh
and i was looking at i'm like this is
awesome and i
i poured the oil i poured the oil in it
uh what is that yang can cook yeah get
the other picture on though
right that's good i put the oil in it
and i um i put a towel okay
under my butt oh this is a whole process
oh it's a whole ceremony oh yeah
oh yeah yeah are you watching a video or
is this all nice i'm gonna get to that
bro
i'm jumping and what is it so i lay the
towel down
and i was on my back and then
it got lopsided because i was because
it's pretty heavy
so i'm with my iphone i was just pretty
happy dude
do you have a nicki minaj what's good
about it don't worry about it that's my
business
um i'm trying to look at the i uh you
know the video
and it a lot it like went lopsided
so all the oil everywhere yeah
dude it's pretty heavy if you have that
veal build okay
dude you have that build like you're
gonna be
definitely it's a little feely don't you
think it's normal behavior though right
oh there's nothing wrong with it being
happy no yeah i'm not i'm not listening
i'm not
shutting you for doing this with that
black box yeah
but is there you feel like there's a
racial tone to it do you feel like
there's a reason why you're like taking
it out on these
on these blacks do you know just that's
the way it came
okay oh yeah but do you wish it was
yellow red i would have done the same
was it a mystery box yeah that's not
yeah i don't know
all butts matter here so would you um
would you like a real
black butt though do you think you could
find like a real black grenade
i'm just trying to help him out here so
he's rid of this hey i love all women
man you know
i don't care about the color yeah but
sure buddy but what do you want though
you know what i'm saying
yeah you have a type you know it would
help us navigate through this that's a
problem you're not helping us help you i
like it all right all right
hot's hot you like hot yeah your type's
hot yeah and what kind of oil you put in
there hot oil
um it's a specific one you use for a
flashlight uh
it's uh it gets hot the never mind i
shouldn't have it it gets uh so you
squirt it in there
and uh but you know what the best thing
to use is
what and this is to all my uh
single dudes out there that it feels
better than a flashlight
and he doesn't he may he basically means
wrestling fans giving you guys
that's what he's talking about this is
the inside [ __ ]
wrestling fans let's don't say single
dudes overall
okay these girls are my single brothers
out there
i don't think single black men are using
these are
[ __ ] like this points i'm telling you
and it's this is
really cost effective you should cut a
avocado in half and put mayonnaise and
half of it there you go that's there's a
um
latex glove you put a little uh vaseline
in there
oh or um which shirt lotion your mom's
house
yeah yeah so latex glove
dang i mean so you've been you're i mean
you're a real veteran of this
sometimes when i'm out i go to in-n-out
burger and i get a double-double because
their employees wear latex gloves
i turned john no so you have if i blow
because i i asked for
i said hey i'm a germaphobe can i have
oh yeah this is if i run out there's
almost double in the
draft session yeah two that those are
two sessions
wow yeah what a great setup that's my
secret so that's gonna help a lot of
guys out there
okay and will you do this on like a
windowsill or where are you doing this
do i want to know what are you doing
it's about your little studio is it like
a thing where you want heights like are
you doing like in a death defying area
you're doing it in a way no i mean you
need a portable heater might help
oh those kill poor people all the time
yeah yeah so you have to heat it up i
mean these are my little secrets every
year in chicago google that
nick portable heater kills oh yeah
impoverished family it's science
i bet you the top five articles are in
chicago
but uh it's a real ceremony they got a
question yeah it is it is and
you never just do it old-fashioned huh
you mean just your hand
oh i haven't done that out in depth man
are you telling this this guy's
the ninja of masturbation dude
apparently dude this guy's wacky chan
okay this guy's the elon musk of busting
an artificial axis man
elon [ __ ] bust you guys haven't done
this i feel like i'm talking a little
bit look i'm trying not to jerk off
i'm excited about my new studio the last
thing i wanted to hear about in it
is and i you know what i'm sorry fatal
fire that killed my uh
space heater right there boom jesus and
then here's the crazy part
they sell them right above it so how
much is it this is the sick part of that
see he's looking forward
what is the
so that could heat up a whole house i
mean it could or you could
let's go back to that top article next
oh you're right right there just
let's see i'm both in the same scene
there if you don't fire them yeah
i got you yeah let's see there's a
chicago one you can shop but at the same
time
fatal fire that killed mother and
daughters linked to space heaters
but then also sells them up above there
you go that 74
one look oh okay dude forty dollars
and get the 24 one at that point here's
what i would do
put two fireballs of your candy and just
blow on your kids back
okay for 74 dollars i would not risk
killing get a king-sized bag of [ __ ]
hot tamales and blow in your kid's face
man
and here is uh here's a young fella
right here
and we this is uh our first king at her
sting it of the evening and we've got a
new wrinkle for it uh
stevie took a break last night from
pleasuring himself off the boulevard for
you guys and he hit the boulevard to get
some responses
sunset did you really stevie yeah sunset
oh hollywood boulevard you're a brave
man wow
yo fat patrick it's kyrie here from
rhode island with my buddy jerry
and i got a king of stinger for you guys
today we're talking bike helmets
brandon i know you'd be rocking one
every day when you're on the thick bike
rides
theo i'm pretty sure i remember you
saying you'd rather your dad have gotten
cte then
you know you know that he ever used the
bike helmet but beside the point
i want to know what you guys think are
we king and bike helmets we stinging
them
gang gang buzz buzz no one's look cool
in a bike helmet man
ever what's up jerry everyone looks like
they're on the short bus in those bike
helmets yeah i would rather go
look if i go to heaven because i don't
have a bike coming on and so be it man
i tell you what i posted a picture
several times on a bike helmet and i got
lit up by fans let's see get a helmet
but your son when he sees you without a
helmet on respects you
any dad that pulls into the garage with
a bike coming on and his son is
somewhere looking at him yeah
it's over the kid didn't know the word
yet and i heard my son go [ __ ]
that's fair so we all sting it
i'm stinging bike helmets i need all the
brain cells i can so i'm gonna
king it can get yes i'm gonna king it
bike helmets king it for safety right
yeah
that and you know if they look cool if
you ride a bike or something bike
helmets
no we're not doing that
so she wants you to be safe
um bike helmets oh you can get some
really bitching ones safety first
always yeah that's like yeah damn what's
up girl
she got that lighter she's looking for a
grinder is that one she
oh yeah she's a baddie you didn't want
to shoot your shot and go girl you want
to
go
no way he was there i know and he wasn't
digging it
he was not he eventually joined because
she was funny but
now steven when you uh if you do take a
woman out i'd love to get into some of
your dating ideas man because i think
i would love to get a camera involved no
no no you guys
we don't need to do that you have a deep
room i don't even have a car
dude we'll set this that's easy well
we'll get your caretaker some flowers
and get you guys a gift certificate
somewhere you know i think the thing is
about getting you out there man
yeah but you need a car in l.a i don't
have no uber
oh so you can double date with china and
his girl chin you got it
jim does those vlogs he's good with that
camera yeah yeah but you don't drink
though huh
no that's gonna that kind of put eight
dips in
you'll be i don't drink fine just give
them a few more times i don't mind if
they drink though they could just tear
they can do
that's good what do you do dinner i
haven't been there you do korean
barbecue and talk and have fun then
chin's the grand maestro of that grill
man i've been with chin it's amazing you
guys go to quarters and [ __ ]
yeah he's like david blaine on the
korean grill over the course
yeah you like the barbecue i love it
the bang i only like going with china i
don't go with chips yeah smoking on that
book
i've watched a lot of your podcasts like
you know you guys talk a lot about
fighting
you guys never bring up like certain
pride legend dudes
fry you guys never talk about don
franklin early
oh okay you never bring up igor volchan
chin how come you guys don't
just because it's old school man come on
man what's wrong with you
i need to get you some more dvds i got
the whole pride collection
yeah then they're some of the best ever
it's just presented andy cohen
here's what i'm talking about is you
can't he he
he don't know he don't know dude you
don't right
you know eager yeah ukrainian no
remember don't don't
maybe sit this one out there we're gonna
talk fighting here okay the only guy he
knows is dustin pouring because
nuts are down his mouth uh the thing is
is
you gotta remember i fought crow cop i
thought no garrett oh dude we can't hear
god anymore dude i'm about to take a
yeah you watch one championship in
rising dynasty he's 200 years old
what is this question we got coming in
right here from somebody i just got
going on guys
texas and i get a king understand it for
you what's up so elon musk was on
saturday night live
trying to make some memes i guess and uh
maybe nfts or something and
it was awful i don't know if you saw it
but it was hard to sit through the parts
that i watched
uh personally i think it's strange how
he's trying to parlay having money into
being famous
uh it's it's now we see why those things
are kind of
mutually exclusive but uh what do you
guys think about
elon musk coming on saturday night live
y'all king it or stinging no
notice the people that hate on elon musk
are calling in from a one-bedroom
apartment there's a lot of jealousy
there
you can't beat the oh yeah that's the
reason why you get the most hate he's
the real
man in the world that's not what he i
don't think that that's what this young
fellow talking about i think he's
talking about do you see him on saturday
live huh yeah
i thought he was good well i thought he
was funny he's just different he's just
like and he for real he has asperger's
he's not a comedian either dude like
he's but they've had knocked
on their before like this isn't nothing
new
i think he just i think what he's asking
is is it weird
they want to be famous yes agree i think
that's weird there's nothing worse when
a business guy wants to be famous
famous he's been on you know well
rogan's different though right like that
rose is not like
entertainment mainstream right he has
notoriety i think what he would call was
notoriety like i
feel like if you're a fame uh a
businessman then you have more
more like acumen or notoriety you know
like
famous is like i just worry like
how much does him being famous or like
if he starts to get too much into that
world in his brain
yeah how much does that carry over and
you know like he's not paying attention
in a shuttle meeting or something yeah
are we ever gonna get to mars
and on united we lose five united's only
having black pilots from now on yeah so
we're gonna lose all
you know what i'm saying like who are we
gonna lose yes nbc gonna give him a
sitcom and then we never get
that's what he's too busy he's trying to
get to go to more like you guys are
saying dude first of all mars
looks like a [ __ ] i don't know where
you want to go there i don't know why
you want to go there we can't do
[ __ ] there money to do you live in a
bubble but also
here's the thing dudes he's not going
he's just sending
people to build [ __ ] and then once it's
popping like vegas he'll come up there
in about five to six years
yeah he's gonna send some other poor
souls to go up there and die
it was a one-off he ain't you know he
did it once he also loves total recall
so that's what he's trying to do
he's trying to send a girl up there with
three tits i heard should we see what
these people on the street had to say
yeah definitely dude this is so weird
this game is called
king it or sting it king it is a thumbs
up sting it is thumbs down i'm just
going to ask you random questions
elon musk as snl host
no that's a stinget that's stinging
people he's not that funny huh
i don't know he seems a little bit kind
of a little too
uptight for that you know he's inventive
and he's a rich businessman there's
there's definitely that um elon musk as
snl host
thumbs up guys oh yeah tesla yeah
there you go there you go elon musk as
snl host
king interesting why you don't like elon
i don't know
okay okay uh okay okay
all right let's do the tesla but yeah
doesn't mean doesn't mean he can be a
host
right right i got you okay hey you're
honest elon musk as
snl host oh it was very uncomfortable
why why why are you against why are you
against you i like that no i like elon
musk i really do
but in regular interviews he's like
pretty normal and in that it was very
uncomfortable
not a comedian it could be nerves and
whatever have you heard about
you take seven minutes to answer
anything because his ass burgers and
also
blunt too he was probably highest he
didn't smoke a blood he smoked a blunt
he didn't smoke
but also that for elon they said his
brain is so advanced when he talks to
even rogan
it's like us talking a seven-year-old
yeah like it he has to make it in the
layman term so he takes a while to
process
really yeah his brain's so advanced he's
like like a blender almost yeah
dog there you go who finished what she
did
i don't think that would be like a very
good first impression elon musk as snl
host
sting it well why not i don't know he
was it was awkward
yeah it was weird okay he was honest i
mean he's like i have asperger's
there you go and then he was making
weird asperger's
there you go he was good on joe rogan
though right oh yeah
see that's his format yeah yeah see i
should i would like to see asperger's in
the movie
oh yeah starting and it's a bunch of
guys sorry anybody
who once said it's a bunch of guys no
shirts a lot of them because they take
their shirts off a lot when they want to
raise their voice
yeah and they are doing wrestling a lot
aspergers loves wrestling it's almost
very synonymous with each other what is
it
is asp i don't really know let's learn
about asperger's real quick
are you like muscles look what he's
doing with asperger's man
you just say [ __ ] is that usually people
on that side that's tourette's i was
thinking about tourettes
is where they just would they just say
yeah or they have a yeah what is
asperger
i'll tell you about it right here
asperger's characteristics uh mental
things
signs and symptoms basically so let me
google in on that yeah
behavior social interactions verbal and
non-verbal communication
emotion regulation and interpretation
that's basically
wrestling okay really yeah
that's wrestling dude in a nutshell yeah
fake social interaction
yeah they're they're they're just kind
of awesome they're awkward
they're a little awkward oh they're all
social scenarios yes
yeah the undertaker oh the undertaker
guy i thought he worked at a funeral
home
guess what he never worked a day at a
funeral never no but they're
never moved to bodybuilding aren't they
doing it maybe no it's a character
doctor the warrior could barely talk
he'd been a bigger star if he could have
said his dude this set is filthy oh okay
that's what it means
you look at these guys right there
asperger's no that's characters they're
like
[ __ ] there's two i think these guys
are are these guys jewish or these are
real wrestling singlets i actually think
they are are those the bash brothers
yeah and one of them just wrestled this
weekend which made it
it was his seventh decade he wrestled oh
wow
doesn't want to give it up wrestled also
means he had a carrot at lunch
so at this age some of the terminology
is a little different he won though
uh but he won you follow it huh nick
uh i just teach you yeah nick's picks
nick
speaking wrestling now i lost 200 on her
broccoli
we uh try our new segment shark take for
segments
yeah first man i want to say thank you
to brian johnson who put this studio
together man
amazing man oh is this new yeah no you
don't
yeah hey man you don't realize the
upgrade come on stevie come on man
when did you guys do this over the last
time
oh what's new is that this the sign yeah
the whole difference oh that that's new
that's no that's new that's nice oh
guys so that is new
that's new okay this is new it's clean
man
so we're gonna let connor in and he's
gonna get 30 seconds
bring him in dude to pitch us on an idea
yeah is it conor mcgregor's gonna pitch
us on whiskey
maybe fair play to the lads yeah can you
hear me oh yeah
yes hey mate how you going man that's
australian yeah i'm good how are you man
he's throughout the country yeah but not
australia what's up brother
i'm good brilliant how are you man i'm
great man what do you got for us man
yeah so um the idea is like confessions
time
so basically what what people would do
is call in
with like the deepest darkest
confessions so it could be a crime
they've committed or some sexual kind of
induced
activity and you guys kind of have to
interact with a guest
and figure out whether it was justified
or not oh
that's fun that's a good idea that's fun
you know there was a podcast called
apology line
it's a crime docu-series um on
uh podcast and this guy created a line
where peop
in new york where people call in and
just confess whatever they want to get
off their chest and they go anonymous no
cops to get involved nothing
so people were calling in like you know
wives or husbands calling back i cheat
on my wife i cheated on my husband
and then eventually a real serial killer
calls i was like
thank you for making this man i feel so
good i'm killing tonight
but i feel better because i can call in
and confess
and then hope they he goes through he
keeps calling in they're tracking the
circle yeah it's fascinating
did it really have anything it was real
or not here's the thing i'm going to
split for you
if you're in the middle of the series in
three two one spoiler
the cops obviously got word of this and
started tracking dude and figuring out
where he was calling from
they went to his house and figured out
he was full of [ __ ] he was never a
serial killer
but he would send him pictures and all
sorts of [ __ ] and grim
details but he would just make up the
whole scene himself
they found out the guy was full of [ __ ]
and the man was how old did they know
anything else about the man was he
sagittarius
someone said a lot of serial killers are
sagittarius as well oh answer i thought
they would be scorpios
maybe squirrel i like your idea though
dude i like it could get dark though you
know it could get
there it is laundry did that it's great
it's fan six part series i think it's
[ __ ] fantastic
does conor have anything he wants to
confess yeah you have anything you want
to confess dude
start with you man fair play to you i
have to be careful
because my girl's in the house but i've
been using her credit cards
for cats only funds for about six months
um so like i don't want to tell her you
know i mean i've just been telling her
i'm buying a lot of food
but i'm seeing a lot of feet do you feel
better confessing that
i feel better yeah i feel better i've
got a lot of pictures
are you are you digging the content
cat's providing on her only fans i don't
see it
so i don't know top tier top tier
wow good for her good for you man connor
that's a good suggestion man thank you
so much for where you calling in today
from
yes boys um so yorkshire in like near
leeds
in england oh yeah yorkshire puddings
yep oh yeah yeah i saw uh michael
bisping eating some yorkshire pudding
the other day on his
instagram yeah that's it
that's it gravy chicken and yorkshire
puddings that's all we eat and what
about
essex man you ever been down in essex is
it [ __ ]
i've never been to essex very different
like people from down south
they're very like um like stucco yeah
whereas up north we're very friendly
very kind
like louisiana hey man that's where i'm
headed then when i get there i'm going
up north man
that's a great idea though brother glad
you got off your chest man hopefully
your girl don't watch the show
cat's gonna lose a subscriber yeah well
cheers to you connor have a good day man
and uh youtube
good luck to you take care brother the
only problem with that you could
incriminate yourself if you say the
wrong [ __ ]
they can't track you though now do you
get worried cb about like if you
um interact with women oh yes
oh you're right he might be at work now
he's covered he's in hot yes
i am at work sorry i'm not radio no
sorry dude i didn't know you were
working are you are you a nurse
no no i'm a ballet okay oh sweet where
at a big community home in la jolla
right right up the street
oh san diego oh nice man that's great up
there oh sweet man we got stevie we
being in the studio today
hey stevie i used to watch your vlogs
how's it going hey
what's up good good
okay
i'm sorry so nikki uh you got 30 seconds
to uh pitch these guys your idea
okay my idea is san diego is a new la
i changed my mind no you got it
you gotta let them know this segment
idea first
the second idea oh the as far as the
segment
yeah uh the segment is where you know
somebody like me calls in gives an
opinion oh change my idea
oh my god you know like the me
that's a great idea the stephen crowder
changed my mind changed my mind is that
what he does but
he does we could do silly stuff he did
like all political [ __ ] yeah
dude that's a great idea i think um so
his your so your idea of san diego
changed my mind
and we got stevie here today that's
perfect because stevie is
la the new is san diego the the you know
i haven't been i'm from poway
so uh and he wrestled also he wrote
wrestle from probably
um but i haven't been there in decades
so i don't i wouldn't be able to give
you a good consensus on that because i
haven't been there in like
decades but he did pin a black sphincter
the other day okay
yeah and oiled up sphinx yeah in
but no dude i think look hopefully it's
not the new la i mean it's harley's
opening up doug
no but hopefully it's not the new la
just because of what la is at least san
diego i feel like there's a
um more laid back yeah it's more laid
back fresh air
it's like less people la jolla
it's slower paced but it's still jammed
up still a lot of people
i feel like not compared to l.a it's
crazy dude
san diego traffic's no punk though man
when you're driving homeless here dude
yeah for sure we don't got then that
homeless people swords yeah so they
could help we're going to get them
offend themselves against each other
yeah swords and cash that's intense
yes yeah like wow
you got you got that awesome uh uh
mirror out there too
in in san diego i think he's running for
a california governor right
i follow politics i'm pretty ignorant
yeah i think he is he he's a bit of a
beast he
i'm ignorant he's a republican yeah he's
a better yeah well as far as politics
yeah i hear you yeah man i love san
diego to theo's point i hope it doesn't
turn to la it's because it's a nice
getaway like
when we do a weekend at la jolla it's so
nice to get away and
there's not so many people it's not so
[ __ ] crazy i need a fish burrito and
just relax oh yeah out here i got my
head on the swivel man
homeless trying to stab you in the neck
with covered needles and [ __ ]
yeah i'm with supplies dude outside my
house it was just lined up with
tents and it's like they have netflix
set up in their
laptops yeah it's crazy yeah so they had
a homeless guy near us the other they
got door dash dropped off at the park
how crazy is that
dude you go to austin you go to austin
they're homeless they have cars parked
outside their tents
you don't have a door what the [ __ ]
unreal
yeah now they're right by father joe's
so they they park their cars and they
have meetings and
yeah they're organized hopefully the
army will fight them soon
someone needs to but nikki thank you so
much for your suggestion man that's a
great idea yeah that's a brilliant idea
best one we've had so far we've only had
two but thank you so much
see he didn't need to know that though
he would have went away feeling good
but he still feels good he feels better
because of the honestly every time i
ready while they're probably looking for
me
good luck brother hide out baby go rogue
dude great idea dude
hide in the ceiling the differences of
opinions yeah i know i love it you know
what i mean
yeah changed my mind that's a great idea
changed my mind
what would you have us change your mind
roebuck what do you think in the back
meet juan short people the new hotness
changed my mind yeah what would be to
change my mind
unpopular opinion um
tick-tock people are actually talented
oh that's a good one
that was a good one it doesn't say
something like [ __ ]
fish tacos suck changed my mind
it's too short of time aren't they
little clips they're it's all dancing
clips
you know there's like now talented
compared to what christian compared to
like
like [ __ ] johnny depp or something
like what's your talent level here
well he's just saying talented like i
thought you were saying what's my
popular opinion uh like people on
popular opinion people who
think they're dancing like doing the
videos
dancers are like listen i'm not gonna
hate on the hustle they're obviously
doing something right and people are
paying attention so
if that's their lane i don't give a [ __ ]
dude like obviously they're good at that
i'm not good at dancing doing tick tock
or you but then they're not good at
podcasting or stand up so it's teach
their own if they're making bank doing
that more power to them how do you make
money on tick tock dude when i was young
ep
the only tick tock was like somebody
that had epilepsy i feel like
yeah like that was the only they didn't
have any now it's like a profession
this is walmart meets jackass oh wow
pure talent oh yeah is he okay oh
oh the girl says he okay christian
i'm good yeah it's horrible
that one wasn't my best one but i mean i
got some that kind of blue like i got
one that blew it
in man and that is uh
and that you know what we can't change
your mind
no mind changing yeah that's wild bro i
wonder if something on tick-tock if
people have ideas or what
uh our guy even
our our buddy who's on his way i said
that you guys are thinking about it
you guys i'm not sorry it's a new thing
for me
not you sorry oh no you're an idiot i
was gonna let it slide because you just
got off a plane so i thought
ah he's a little cloudy up top you know
our buddy who uh wanted to wrestle
stevie he said if stevie was too afraid
uh once he gets down there he'll fight
christian look man you know a lot of men
you see them somewhere and they don't
have an erection
dude don't have an erection or they're
losing their hair too dude
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss
more than 50 50 million
bros in the us suffer from losing their
hair dude male pattern baldness
mpb man not you dog that here is getting
long daddy and some men take the snake
some men will even take a limp wiener
and put it on their head to make it
and color it up like hair fooling nobody
to cheat keeps
offers a simple stress free way to keep
your hair all right low cost stream and
start just 10
per month keeps offers generic versions
all right
shows up discreet little package proven
results son
prevention is the key treatments can
take four to six months
so act fast if you're ready take action
and get the long
locks like mr theovan over here go to
keeps.com
cats again that's keeps.com cats
receive your first month of treatment
for free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash cats murder all right this
episode is brought
brought to you by unleash with the dogs
with dingo and danny
a new podcast fueled by monster energy
on leash gets up close and personal with
the best in alternative action and
motorsports
get ready for untold stories career
defining moments and inside secrets from
the world's best athletes and
trailblazers
don't miss out on all the action new
episodes
drop every two weeks on mondays listen
wherever you get your podcast
or watch on monster energy's youtube
unleashed with danny and the dingo
fueled by monster energy what's going on
dog
you've got 30 seconds pitch pitch these
guys your idea
what's a good idea what you think jamie
what you think is a good segment
segment uh what was it whip it or ditch
it
you can drive that bad boy around around
the block
grab that bad boy into a ditch damn
oh that's pretty good too whip it or
ditch it people say this
picture rides rip it or ditch it yeah
they got the cleanest chevy sonic on
youtube oh okay oh
i'll get out to check that out man he
does it's eerily similar to chide my
ride which we haven't gotten a lot of
submissions for in the past
but uh i like it specific it's fun for
sure
if you drive it can you drive wherever
you want or you just drive it
how far do you have to drive it does it
matter
oh it doesn't matter okay it kind of
just flex on people in it
was it a sports car or a normal corolla
like what well
well that's the problem though that's
kind of a car that's a contest like
if it's chin's car from high school it's
like a rice rocket you know
some people did get a honda civic yes it
was a honda civic tourism
a lot of white girls that date black
guys when i was growing up drove honda
civic
asians i love that yeah yeah asians love
them with the big exhaust and the big
fans and [ __ ]
what's that player i said google chevy
sonic and check out that thing
is that yours yeah yeah okay chevy sonic
we'll check it out
david thank you so much we'll check it
out right now well it's a good idea
brother
we'll start with that one whip it or
ditch it whip it or see this chevy sonic
nick
let's see this thing and how um
and what about a station wagon they
don't have a truck or
did your mom have a station wagon and
sorry to hear i you
who's your mom didn't pass away did you
mpv no my dad did your daddy
oh yeah dude remember bobby shoot me the
pictures of him with your dad like
laying there deceased that was crazy
oh he got he got like uh death visions
yeah
in the hospice that's what he wants have
you heard of this yes
it's when you hallucinate oh bobby got
done no my
my pops oh wow oh like three days before
he passed he was tr he was looking
he he they took him off the feeding tube
and he
he he was like catatonic but then i was
there watching rocky too
um with my ipad and then out of nowhere
he he was tripping out on the ceiling oh
wow
and he was seeing [ __ ] what if he saw
like an angel or something i think he
saw ghosts or something
that's angels it through dynasty yeah
yeah that's that's dark you can't be
seen ghosts i don't know oh that's a
chevrolet spark
that's a sound upgrade oh sorry it
looked like a chevy spark you know
okay that's your whip that's your whip
jamie
that's the whip that's a little short
bust van that's what
it's a little hatchback yeah oh dude
that's a suppository you put enough lube
on the front you could drive that right
into somebody's keister
right into somebody's german butt dude
and it was rip it or what was it
whip it or ditch it i'm gonna have to
ditch that thing you don't like the
chevy spark
sorry dude i'm gonna have to ditch that
thing you don't like chevrolet
most people fail me not not the biggest
chevy fan you don't have a you don't
like a chevy spark plug
against chevrolet yeah no it's wrong
i know you're afraid
of videos do do the do the chicks dig at
my man
no i got white she digs it it's hard
that's all that matters then dad
it's hers gas mileage it's a little car
yeah it's hers man
yeah no jamie i think it's it's not bad
man thank you so much for the submission
jamie we appreciate it that was fun dude
good luck in that thing
would i be able to get a date if i had a
chevy spark
i'm not in l.a no do you have a driver's
license though uh i don't want you out
of spark no put some rims on that [ __ ]
baby if i lived in a different state i
could
yeah you go to like ontario you go to
more inland i would need something way
better than that
out here yeah why didn't you and bobby
ever do a podcast together oh good
question ask bob
ask him i mean bob he him and griffin
should have done one and
i don't know but i mean him and griffin
didn't come out of the same person's
body i know
did it ever did you ever pitch that to
him or no
yeah let him do his own [ __ ] yeah yeah
sometimes tough with family you know
yeah it is
there's some underlying issues there
who's more than the protector you feel
like over y'all's lives
you or bobby over what though over the
other one who's been like the bit who's
been like the protector who's the who's
the papa bear in the relationship
oh he's my older brother for so him for
sure yeah
yeah do you feel like he's always really
kind of like
um looked up to you or what when i
wrestled i think because i was a star
wrestler at my high school so he's
a poway yeah he drove up to the state
tournament in his uh truck to
in stockton back then to support you oh
yeah yeah i choked
yeah oh yeah you said yeah choked yeah
who'd you fight the pressure i was
ranked second here
in cali and the pressure gotcha oh yeah
double i just lost
i froze uh you know it's like you know
you're a fighter
yeah you [ __ ] imagine being in the
octagon and you just freeze
yeah tonight you don't even no take down
defense no nothing
that would be me yeah it was a white boy
oh that different race yeah
yeah well you can say who he was say
what he was i don't know i mean i
i know junior
senior year i'm sure you saw him you got
a good look at him now
bobby supported you bobby's or was he a
jelly monster
did he make a poster or not he'd go to
uh county championships he'd go to
masters
and what was he doing cheering or just
having snacks well he had long hair he
was just in the front row cheering wow
yeah what a good brother yeah good dude
uh we've got a flop my aunt this week
this is uh aunt terry
and she's going to be introduced what's
up theo what's up brendan i'm yvonne
i'm from the 559 in the central valley
in california
near fresno so
this here is my mom her name is terry
she's known as our crazy aunt in our
family
all of my cousins know that she is crazy
terry she's
60 years old the big 6-0 she always has
a beer in her hand
she loves sedan she is crazy she's 411
like a little chihuahua um and she
always
wants whiskey when she's feeling frisky
you know what i mean oh yeah um she
always got that
jaunt hanging out she hopped up yeah
yeah that vibe somewhere because she'll
whip him out
oh yeah at any time that she's feeling
whoo so um ms 60.
oh yeah you're crazy if you don't think
she was part of that family back in the
day
oh terry down that spawn ranch she
looked like that little lsd
cinnabon yeah yeah yeah looks like
shooting i hate ashbury man that's where
she was
oh yeah dude now would you take that
down uh steve oh i watched granny pour
oh am i all into the granny
oh yeah that's you that's your genre pie
all day this is what i'm noticing about
you stephen i just i just wanted to say
maybe that's my problem granny
no what oh
edit that out and i was gonna i wasn't
gonna nick
don't worry santino will let you say it
don't worry okay okay
here's what i'm concerned about right
now is just what about
um i feel like since you say like the
the virtual the uh cause i said would
you go out with her and you're like oh i
i
watched great everything's no but it's
all virtual for you there's no reality
fair point you're not making a real
custody it's a different dimension of
the porn dimension
but no you're lost in a different
dimension of all of it you don't have a
car where you place this association man
you don't have a girlfriend but you play
porn you don't have
um you don't have a girl but you but you
drew a picture of a girl you have like
this
you can have the art but you don't have
anything you're living in an alter
yes reality it's like a ready player one
yes
i'm in a different dimension oh i didn't
even talk about the oculus
oh you have a video game of porn yeah
the virtual world wow
you're in it they're right there in
front of you wow
so that's the future brother yeah it is
yeah you can do that
that's the future if you have if you
don't have a caretaker that drives you
across town in a van all the time hey
real quick that's okay
stevie that's your future
is it that's my future that's your
future oh god
it's gonna be fun dude you'll be making
this that's so sad bro you'll be naked
i'm so sorry i just i just visualized
that
yeah i see a lot of panda express on
[ __ ] postmates
and a lot of oculus yeah dude granny
porn
oh is that there's no there's no hope or
no i mean it depends what you want man
guys it's tough
you guys are the alphas here i'm beta
here dude you're gonna end up you're
gonna end up out there making like
candles out of like tracy chapman
butt holes or something you're not going
to be doing real well bucka
so how do i fix it we need to fix it
right now guys i need to get rid of all
that
we need to fix it right now i need to
get rid of all that what do i have to do
i need to i need your advice
you need to get with a real you need you
with
yep you need to start getting with a
real human being making a real
connection yeah and get rid of the fake
black
black butt and all that oil that's what
what about the porn what about the
pornography
i would limit i would limit it i don't
think it needs to stop don't hold turkey
no you know you want your dick to fall
off what you want to do is maybe once a
week
brendan no you can't do it once a week
he's already doing it how many times a
week are you touching your body you feel
like with your hands once every night
it's a part of my sleeping ritual
that's not a sleeping ritual no no no
it's a part of
it though you know it's like you tell me
why you're down sleeping
dude do you know some people wind up
with a red one that's a part of it
that's his thing
he's down with that flesh level i'd
rather have you drink
than jerk in your body all over the tell
me that using your body like that just
spraying your body out yeah all guys
don't other dudes do this how do you do
it all the time chin are you doing this
kind of stuff what are you guys doing
help me out come on
come on help me out here
don't do it often one of these cobras
dude
what do i do today i want to make a
change first because you scared me with
the
that's what i'm not trying to say and
i'm saying no no no i just i i was like
the movie click
and we fast forward and that's your life
yeah when i see
because here's what i envision i
envision a it kind of it's like a
cambodian version
of um what's that movie where the guy
comes and gets them and they go back and
see their
they go back and see what their family
was going to be like if they if nothing
happened family man
yeah it's like family man remember
family owned nicholas cage or mr destiny
no no not mystery that's a good move
that's a great stop you've seen it i
haven't seen it right now
great here's what i'm talking about
though is uh it's at christmas time the
night before
uh uh yeah oh scrooge you're coming
scrooge
so it's like bill murray great movie
it's like bill murray but here's the
they take you to your past and they look
in the window and it's just you
masturbating into like a void of like
there's like
no trons and stuff hooked into your head
there's like a big huge like
portal with light coming out you're
wearing one of those dentist things over
your eyes
yeah it's an nc-17 scrooge yeah stronger
than the last
of the universe and it's christmas night
okay then they take you to your future
40 years from now and it's the same you
think you're gonna go around the block
to a different place and they come back
to the same window because there's
nothing else to do and it's you again
but this time you're having like a
lemonade or something
yes but it's still doing all the other
stuff teeth whitening
if that's me that's how it ends
i'm telling you you just spoiled the
movie but yeah no no i'm just saying
because you just said that's my future
that's
i'm not going to let that happen so we
need to get you on the road
what's that what's that dating site
what's the one you said
right right i need to get me aria yes
get me something better than the chevy
spark
right yeah start working out maybe
exercising something
bad idea maybe change your diet maybe go
to up runyon
you sure hike up running in a couple of
days dude like work on that here you got
the dope kicks
yeah yeah
uh we'll close it out with a debate club
what's up big dog yo yo what up brandon
what up theo coming at you guys from
sunny san fernando valley and i got a
debate club for you
all right so summer's right around the
corner
and stuff has finally opened up so
people are doing more stuff
and you know we don't all have that gang
gang guap
so we can't be taking flights got to go
with the classic road trip sometimes
right
sure so my question is on a road trip
what's better being the driver or riding
shotgun me personally i gotta go with
riding shotgun so i can smoke my little
weak pen maybe have a little roadie and
control that music
so
gang gang buzz
yeah stevie this is not that's not how
you start nope
actually it's good practice what would
you say if this was a young lady what
would you say
beautiful hair dude don't say dude
she's not going to like that beautiful
hair bro
don't say that that's a beautiful
hairstyle yeah i know
i just want to be an active human being
oh yeah this guy
is definitely beige power man that's the
future right there yeah
say it yeah he's getting matched up on
tinder for sure here's what we need to
do we need to have people submit some
dates i think for steve
no stevie weeby goes on a date yeah and
people submit
ideas what are we gonna do take them to
in-n-out burger dude
they're gonna pitch they're gonna pitch
you on a dude yeah dude i don't have a
car
dude dude that's that's that's that's
that's that's the haircut the two bus
down sunset come on dude your caretaker
will take you that's my neighbor
good friend we did it with chin happily
in their relationship
you did it your girlfriend gets paid by
the hours
his good friend also is getting paid
so this is a lost cause my whole no i
lost cause dude there's a lot of hope
the fans are gonna help yeah i like that
the fans what are you doing there
i like that i got you dawg i like that i
like it
cause dude i remember because i when i
came over to your place steve i remember
you had the girl you had the four and a
half
years yeah did you do it
yeah i got complacent you had the magic
though you got to keep
working on yourself yeah but you also
got to keep working on then you have to
work on the relationship that's
look it happened to me man i got dumped
by a girl recently and it's because
how long were you with her i was with
her for three and almost three and a
half months
okay not long yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what it doesn't help that i'm in la
i think it does help there's a lot of
things you know what i mean
san diego or you get killed in stockton
you get beaten up
fresno you're gonna get beat down
memphis dude you would get you'd be on
black
dot com yeah i would love it in an hour
on memphis okay
if we do it in memphis i'll take i'll go
to that dude
you'd be one of the hottest japanese
women in mexico no no no
and i'll get cowboy boots i'll do the
whole thing dude
flannels dude i think i think fans make
great ideas for stevie then we pick one
and send them on it yes
we'll cover it all transportation
everything dude
yeah sure yeah yeah i want to see for
you man
now so this is getting away from the
oculus and then you gotta get late
one last run maybe i'll quit it with the
latex gloves that's a bit much
well it's also those are free beefs
those are for serving those are for food
service women at the uh
it's for gay men at the high school yes
it's also for people that make the
animal style burgers at in and out so
maybe stop that
hey we'll edit that part too huh but
stevie how do you even use
you said you do it you actually stick it
in the fingers or you just use it as a
glover
no i use it as a flashlight
so you prep it by opening up the
the glove and then i squirt uh aloe vera
lotion in it
so you squeeze a little bit but this is
all though i'm missing a detail
when the lotion gets in there you do a a
mr miyagi
oh so this is the glove you do a mr
miyagi to
to disperse the lotion you don't want it
dry
and then you the portable heater
you're gonna die man yeah we gotta let's
let's stop with the
the gloves that's me the first step
today today we're gonna stop
banking here's what i thought this is
what's crazy to me
i thought you were this guy who had
gotten here illegally or something
sure and your parents he didn't know
what happened to him except you and your
brother ended up on a wrestling team
kind of like newsies but like wrestling
yeah and then something else happened
and blah blah blah
and here you are you got caught outside
of the building on a day you weren't
supposed to be here and you were sad
but now i'm really into it yeah you're
out here
our apartment doing some mischievous
[ __ ] yeah yeah and i know about that
that's the dark arts brother and i've
been there gotta get out of the
apartment yeah
yeah another step but one step at a time
let's just ditch the gloves for today no
more animal style gloves no more latex
gloves no more lotion
no more porn hey i was off porn for
three months
wow did you like i was doing it i did
the whole thing
did you really yeah yeah it was terrible
cruising meetings
spawned all that wow did it feel good it
felt great
so let's go back to that i know it start
working out
it's hard there's nothing sadder to me
than whenever i'm doing masturbation
yeah you feel you don't feel good about
yourself
and especially if you don't have a tv or
anything in your house because then you
just masturbate and you just sit there
and you feel low especially when you
have a latex glove
you know wrapped around it oh yeah
especially when it looks like your penis
is about to serve seconds to some
school child yeah it looks like howie
mandel's closer
yeah plus you have a ritual of cleaning
you have to take soap and
it's a lot it's a it's a hole it's a
whole thing it's a waste of time stevie
we got to back off our own bodies man
you got to look to the lord as well i
think bub give it a break
wait god you're right i could pray about
it
well there's a lot of things you could
do i just think that yeah i just want to
see i just want to see you i want to see
you have that family dude
and that what big beans you know just a
human connection for you is important
you're a family man too i mean you learn
as you go you have and there you go
right there there's howie mandel
that's you stevie oh you guys don't have
to bring that up huh
that's what it is
dude brian johnson thank you so much for
this new studio brian
unbelievable unreal you guys happy
yes yeah stevie thanks for coming back
man i just
we love you man you guys like the street
i love you guys the street stuff do you
guys like the streets
i loved it i liked it okay so you loved
it i liked it okay
what i liked the most was you being out
there and being brave enough to do it
and you taking some time out of your
life
to just do something nice for us man
yeah no no no any time no you keep you
busy
and i think look man we'd love to have
you back even on the next episode if we
want to talk about
getting you some submissions and see if
we can't find a girl it's a date
that's more of like a i don't need the
petty thing you know i just you know oh
no
this isn't petty this is friends here's
here's the thing dude and how about we
get the submissions
we pick the best day you can decide if
you want to do it or not
you don't there's no pressure either
yeah then you can just decide you know
what i don't like because it's like now
it's out there in the universe it's like
oh that's the guy that
was on the dating thing on king you know
no it's gonna be that's the guy that
jacks off into latex gloves
yeah that's the guy that's that's the
guy that's blowing up street balloons
with his semen
you know what i'm saying like yeah
that's a way of risking yeah
i think i think you put the crown on
some kid's head and it weighs
four pounds yeah so you're saying this
other thing is more healthier yes
yeah we're trying to get you on the
healthy track because we're all
healthier than what i'm doing at home
correct
we're all looking for that's all we're
gonna do man so it's healthier that's a
healthy snack then again no pressure if
you don't want to do it you don't have
to do it
now that looks like bobby the lower one
what is that that's an ewok
it's an ewok what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
but you feel my brother theo's point
that looks like your brother in a beer
outfit yeah
looks like your brother and oh his body
just
every whole thing the whole thing is
more like you walk from star wars and
the scepter also and what else
yeah the top one does not look like him
it looks like something like that
it's like a saw museum and there he is
that's yeah spot that's him let's be
honest man good job you guys love bob
i love him oh one of my favorite people
i love him man i just wish i got to
spend more time with him you know
yeah oh yeah he's still alive so you
guys can make how many minutes a week do
y'all spend together you think i haven't
seen them in
months yeah i do really i've seen them a
couple times so
oh you guys are uh at the store didn't
the store open oh yes
the door's open yeah so you guys will
find a limited capacity but yeah they're
open
it's open it's true yeah man i'm just so
happy you came back
and i'm just worried that after
everything that happened with you
getting stuck out there and all the no
no it's all good
the alarms and the argument with the guy
out there no he's good
he's good and the good friends drama
like we're here now
yeah yeah i didn't even know about all
that oh yeah the bad yeah
please check out scissor bros you'll
love the the the challenge
i will say this i watched the first 11
minutes
of y'all's episode number three thank
you for being honest loved the editing
loved the scissors hanging in the
background and the giraffes
loved the um zoom
effect that ken burns zoom effect that
they use in the civil war photos
editing yeah um what else did i love i
love the compassion that you guys have
for each other music we played the
keyboard he does a saxophone
yeah yeah yeah i loved
yeah i just love you you guys have a
very simpatico nature
yeah it's just silly it's just silly yes
we just heard it almost i
almost wished that if you took all the
it's almost like sesame street
that's what we're trying to do like a mr
rogers sesame street kind of like
wayne's world type of thing that's what
i feel like phyllis has been treated for
people that have been like electrocuted
or something it's a big adventure
yeah and i also love that when you come
on here because you're so different than
me and theo it's such a good vibe well
he ain't that different from me
you guys get along for the most part
though you guys are having a big deal
yeah you guys are home you guys get
older he's one of my best friends but
you're i'm more like you then you're
more like
i'm more like you stevie than he is yeah
you think that masturbation shit's weird
yeah i just
here's what i don't want to judge you
but i think it's a problem
i don't want to like i said with the
scrooge dude i don't want to see us come
back to the window again
and it's you in there with another
oculus and you got an oar here's gray
you have an underground railroad running
into your butt
and it's like all virtual you know what
i'm saying you have a harriet tubman
dancing on your stomach and you're just
spraying the gift that god gave you out
of your room
and for no reason yeah you're just
shooting blanks we don't want that for
you
i want to see a family i want to look in
that window and see a small little
family
yeah everybody's on the piano you're
playing the piano your kids dancing on
the last two yeah
that's the way it should quit wasting
that icing yeah dude yeah so one of your
kids is just spraying sriracha
when you when you nut you're wasting a
part yeah it's going
to be some that could be your potential
future just going down the sink with me
a nice young lady and start it's just
going into the glove that's just we're
better than that man we're better
you're right it's meant for reproduction
why am i just nutting
you're wasting time tonight yeah imagine
being your drain that imagine if your
drain had feelings or had
and it's just under your house and it
was like oh i'd have a billion kids down
there yeah but
your drainage was like oh here he goes
again little mcbusty
you know a little chop chop bust bud
your drain's exhausted you know what
else i didn't talk about it takes me
like hours to come okay okay you know
what
let's end on that thank you oh is this
still recording
yeah i'm in that part out please
we can't but edit it out i'm in houston
next week thursday friday saturday
chappelle we got david lucas myself
houston
improv that is may 20 through 22nd and
then oklahoma city bricktown comedy club
is in june get your tickets mr theo
vaughn's back on the road
one of the best in the biz i'm gonna be
back on the road
and i'm telling you guys right now i do
not know my dates but i'll do them in a
second
i got tickets going on sale right now
and uh they're at theovonne.com
tour and that's st louis cincinnati
charlotte durham chattanooga knoxville
wilmington uh wilkes bar
and uh some other places charleston
richmond albany
buffalo columbus and minneapolis but i'm
excited man so go check it out
theovon.com
tour and thank you guys as always for
your support and then all this this cats
coach jacket theo's long sleeve this
dope ass hat
we got hoodies we got all new cats merch
all right so go
get this this is friday crazy though
as you watch on friday this merch will
be available holla
let's go brendan and theo fighter and
weight
i got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning aint the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
on a string
you